it's reaction time and this time i'm
going to react to things that aren't
necessarily all computer science memes
and stuff
but yeah it's time for some
react i don't know this isn't not going
to be related to code at all but
we hit 7k subs
and i gotta do something
weird and hopefully enjoyable all right
check this out
this is a from the win stupid prizes
thought maybe i should just do a whole
win stupid prizes thread because
often what i'm dealing with
is just
stupid things all right i love this
stuff
apparently
these guys were like about to fight or
something kind of flipping out having a
little
whatever this worker comes in is like
just i don't know apparently tries to
calm down the situation dude hits him
for no reason
but this right here this is so good
clayton knocks him out
but if you look look at this move just
wait let me back up
so this dude on the right comes out of
here
oh okay we can't i don't know if you can
inch it forward i don't think i can i'll
just try to click
he comes out he does a swing
dude ducks it
and hits him with a left jab
i think the second punch mitts but that
left jab was like right in the nose or
jaw
boom
knocked him clean out
ducked
he's a fighter
duck left jab boom
yeah maybe don't hit the person that's
trying to help
i want to see him piss himself
good stuff
all right see what else we can find
here we go here we go preparing coffee
this looks epic i gotta meet the music
on it but
it got just leaned perfectly on these
things so it boils over
and just mixes
ah but that's so good
it looks so good it's gonna overflow oh
he turned the burner off okay nice
well played that looks that's amazing
my next random thing i found uh
as long as i live i would not understand
the system
trump mocks reporter with disability did
that really happen
i don't pay much attention to politics
so
i didn't really pay attention to trump
when he was president but did that
really happen or is that like
uh imposed on there
we gotta go to the comments for this one
what is this this is talking about
two-party systems i don't care about
two-party systems i'm wondering if this
actually happened
i guess it did nobody nobody's saying
like i didn't
there's no way that that was just fine
there's no way he just got away with
that that doesn't happen in our world
this is cancel
culture in all reality though i think
cancel culture is not that real of a
thing
i've discovered like
people pretend it's a thing but if you
actually try to do it you need like a
real reason for people to
to cancel someone you can't just get mad
at them for saying one thing they
actually need to do something terrible
so rest assured as long as you're not
terrible you probably won't get canceled
it looks pretty terrible though that's
exceptionally terrible really to at
least i thought people thought it was
i guess there were more are okay with it
than we thought
let's move on
all right here's a little eye bleach
a sheep dog getting chased by a sheep
when your lack of sheepdog experience is
cruelly exposed on your first day of
work
that's great
where's that little lamb sheep i don't
know
it's just funny
all right here's a fun one
cutting things up close in slow motion
copper wire
so satisfying looking
oh there's sound too i'm gonna get the
sound
is that the real sound
i hope this is the real sound
it feels real
they probably just amplified
a lot
well
aluminum
well
uh there ain't nothing like a good old
choosy baker post all right let's check
this one this is apparently for someone
applying for a
graphic designer position
and here's the response they got all
right let's read this
starting with this as part of our
selection process we invited candidates
to design a trial project you were one
of them
before we move forward is quick overview
of how we will collaborate
with you if you wish to join us for a
maximum of four hours to complete you
will get paid ten dollars if the request
is completed and approved by the client
so you're not getting the ten dollars
congrats 250 an hour maybe but probably
not all right if you pass the first
trial you will be enrolled in another
90-day testing phase will you earn five
to ten dollars per assigned project
five to ten dollars
are they missing some zeros
the earnings per project will be
available for withdrawal on your payment
portal once the site project is
completed and approved by the client
so maybe probably not all right
we assign you a minimum of five projects
per day oh we can make up to 25 bucks
per day if you're lucky or 50 i guess
you get a 10 on each
for five projects
that's a
pro that's a lot of work
and you choose to work on your skit okay
to remain on the platform you have to
complete a minimum of five products per
day
potential earnings 25 to 50 per day okay
which we consider as the minimum
designer should get us daily payment
wait if these projects each take like
four hours
four times five
20 hours all right it's 20 hour work
days for uh
up to 50 bucks
lucky you
lucky you're getting this position
do they really think this would work
if you have any other questions don't
hesitate to ask oh i'm sure they got
questions or they probably don't have
any questions they probably
have a delete block that's probably what
they did i would assume
all right let's check out some of the
comments here's the translation we have
a pool of graphic designers that we rely
on most are gone within a few months
high turnover so we plan to exploit use
for as long as we can he quit
okay
people complain about 40 hour work weeks
do you know about that graphic designers
over here doing
20 hour work days
all right let's see what else we got
educational gifts okay a scale model
shows how a mangrove forest stops waves
from damaging the coast okay so waves
going through some mangrove
yeah
just absorbs it that's cool
it's a cool little model
i don't normally get into political
stuff because i have no idea what i'm
talking about but apparently
kazakhstan is in a state of protest
and uh wait they have a place name
atreyu almost betray you
not quite i'm not sure how to say that a
tear route
police station siding with the people
and is against the government
i don't know the story i have no idea
i just thought it was interesting
oh this is cool an inflatable
boat that is apparently homemade
what if it gets a hole in it
i'd be terrified to ride that thing you
hit one sharp stick and pop
you're going down
or maybe it's like super thick plastic
no it's pretty cool though
oh this is a good one
very more relevant to my channel
probably people claiming to be
self-taught
who are you learning from
people who wrote all the books and made
all the videos they learned from
i'm self-taught i've never read anything
i've never watched anything i've just
been 100 isolation learning all this
stuff
yeah right i don't think self-taught is
even
what people mean is i didn't go to
school for this they don't mean
self-taught
self-taught is
yeah
so
stop saying self-taught just say you
didn't go to school for it or you didn't
i don't know you're still you can still
study without school so you can't say
you didn't study it you just
let's move on
relationship problems when your
girlfriend leaves the breakup note on
your playstation saying this isn't
working but you turn it on it works just
fine
all right
that's gonna do it for this video hope
you guys enjoyed it thanks for uh
watching my channel and supporting me it
really does mean a lot to me and i'm
looking forward to producing content and
doing some fun stuff this year so i hope
you'll subscribe and hit the bell i
normally do
tutorials and coding content and devlogs
and stuff like that this is
a very special video
for 7 000 sub mortgage
and i probably should have said all the
stuff i'm saying right now at the
beginning but
you know trial and error and all that
alright see you in the next one peace